all right that was the president of the
United States and the president of
Ukraine Vladimir zielinski in the East
room of the White House after a day long
day of meetings zielinski traveling to
the United States today pretty
unprecedented hadn't been out of the
country of Ukraine in 302 days since uh
President Putin invaded his country
there's a lot to get to he still has a
speech tonight a joint session on
Congress that will happen a little bit
later but we have some time now to get
some reaction from your favorite people
on the five let's start with the judge
Judge Jeanine Pirro who was here
listening along with us and get your
thoughts you know it's interesting when
you put all the numbers together it's
110 billion dollars that we have given
the Ukrainian Aid today almost 2 billion
for the Patriot missile system again I
think the president was very clear that
he didn't want to do anything that would
be other than defensive President Biden
so it's a patriot missile system that
was important
um and I also think that the president
is speaking for congress although
Congress still hasn't approved the
additional 4 45 billion dollars that
Ukraine wants and I suspect is the
reason why the president is here let me
just speak for a second about President
zielinski he is a um he he has a very
friendly way about him he has a very
comfortable way about him
um you know and then I remember I guess
at one point in his career he was a
comedian I think we learned uh he seems
like a very nice guy it's amazing that
he's gotten to the point where he is now
where he's still standing in light of
the damage that's happened to the
Ukraine but I think the big issue for
the American people is this how are we
spending 110 billion dollars uh an
additional 2 billion right now for uh
the Patriot missile system uh when our
own Southern border is not being
protected you know and there's money in
our own bill or Omnibus spending Bill
the 1.7 trillion dollars going for
borders in Tunisia and Jordan and Egypt
and Lebanon why are we doing that and I
think most Americans are saying why are
we spending this kind of money and I
think the answer that's being given and
I'm not really sure where I come down on
it Dana the answer that's been given
right now is look if we don't stop Putin
here in Ukraine then we're going to be
putting more money and possibly boots on
the ground if if Putin goes into Poland
and then NATO kicks in it's a message to
China that it's okay now you can attack
Taiwan so I mean there's a lot more
National Security interest apparently
pending on this money then I think most
Americans realize Harold I think the
judge said it said it well the 110
billion is if we get the 45 billion more
that the Congress is debating just as to
clarify the judge's point but the judge
I think you laid it out very well right
at the end
um I think we should be protecting the
southern border we need a totally
different strategy I think these are two
separate conversations but I think you
define why this is a different
conversation
um and the president I think tried to at
the very end when he said that he looks
at his NATO allies in the in the eyes
and they they want to protect the
sovereign mines in Europe but they don't
want to trigger World War III they also
have energy security considerations
there's so many things that that will
come at us but I was impressed like you
were with with the two of them standing
there this was historic as Dana said
this this President of Ukraine had not
been out of the country uh in 300 days
or since the war started back in
February I wouldn't remember when we
started talking about this because it
happened it seemed so long ago in many
ways and the progress that President
zielinski and his troops and Soldiers
with the help of many around the globe
including us have made should make all
of us as Americans have a have a sense
in a rush of Pride because in so many
ways if they were not able to do this
the ukrainians we would likely have to
do this because what Putin has tried to
do is to redraw and reconfigure the
lines that had been settled since World
War II uh in in Europe and we would have
had to have defended along with our NATO
allies so they have done us a great
service I thank him as well he's
Thanking us but I think them for their
courage and I can only I'm only grateful
also because Putin clearly
underestimated the the the the desire
the hunger the appetite that the
ukrainians have to determine their own
future uh the future of their land the
future of their children uh and I too
like the the sense of humor that uh
zielinski who's at war is still able to
have a chuckle and have a sense of humor
about where he is and uh I think I guess
lastly the fact that President Biden has
also said to him we want you to be
comfortable but we want a negotiated
settlement to this I think that came
across two or three times in President
Biden's remarks and I'm glad he's
leaving room for that because that's the
only way this is going to end that was
notable Jesse zulinski is never going to
surrender and he's never going to
negotiate the guy's Charming but he's a
killer and the fact that he spoke
English tells me
that's not happening because he said the
country wants vengeance and you
understand it because you have widows
you have mothers you have brothers that
saw their sons get hacked down by this
Putin War Machine and they're not going
to say okay let's cut a deal let's do
some reparations you keep the East
they're going to do everything they can
to expel the Russians out of that
territory and then they're going to
bring up some of these Russian generals
on war crimes that's what they want
Biden said the right thing I guess but I
want to hear the man speak from the
heart or the brain instead of speaking
from his notes because that whole thing
was choreographed these were
pre-selected questions he knew what was
coming and I expect more from the
commander-in-chief the Patriot missile
system is an escalation this is our most
high-tech system it's an air defense
system that we have guys trained for
three years how to operate you don't
just hand this thing over and say
Ukraine go for it you're sending
advisors over to Ukraine on the ground
to operate the system for them so when
the missiles are coming in this thing
better be a hundred percent because if
we have guys on the ground that are
getting shot down by Putin's missiles
that's going to be a real problem so
Putin's gonna now Target the Patriot
missile defense system because that's a
huge propaganda win for him if he could
get a missile through but I guess it's
better than having these missiles rain
down on these civilian centers yeah
because he's just been crushing these
utility companies these water systems
and causing Mass civilian casualties
that it just looks like to me that
may or may this winter is not really
going to decide anything in May you hear
it's the muddy season's over Putin's
bringing in 500 000 new guys
Ukraine has captured basically like an
entire uh Battalion of tanks and and
Russian Artillery they're gonna get
those things repaired and it's going to
be a huge Collision in the spring and
we're going to find out who's going to
win this thing hopefully I'll have a
just a quick comment before we get
Greg's which is I wonder at what point
does Biden start to lean on zelinski a
little bit more for a negotiated
settlement because zielinski has said we
need all of 2023 in order to beat them
back but then you're getting right into
2024 and then there's perhaps a
different political calculation and I'm
sure that the Biden team will not want
to be dealing with this in 2024 over to
you Greg well I remember we talked about
when we were talking about the pandemic
and then we were the analogy was we were
going to fight it like a war and then it
switched and we looked at the wars like
we were fighting a pandemic they both
have something in common all data should
be seen as suspicious I remember in the
pandemic the social distancing the six
feet away BS washing down products that
you bought anything that came in
groceries so I think it's the same with
this is the longest fog of war and maybe
I just maybe I've lost my innocence on
this stuff and maybe all war is the fog
of war and you can't trust anything you
hear or you or you see it I think you
know uh Jesse's hit it right it's like
nothing is ever going to be enough and
you have to remind yourself this is our
money and when he said Patriot missiles
and he said thanks I want more Patriot
missiles that's how it's going to go and
that is an escalation I mean 300 if I
300 days ago if I thought we were it was
going to be like this I would be
heartbroken because it was a thing I
didn't want was this law it was like a
war that everybody gets used to it's a
war everybody got used to mainly because
it's like rock sock'em robots right it's
between Russia and the United States but
it's the Russian troops and the
ukrainians are fighting but we are it's
like
we're our limbs aren't getting blown up
you know we're not being killed so I
think that we even saying that I'm super
impressed by zielinski uh I think his
face is going to be on currency thanks
to our currency we should be following
our currency because we both know I mean
we know that Ukraine
they're a little corrupt not as corrupt
as Russia but we need to support Ukraine
because they are our dog in this fight
and they were our dog in this fight well
before the fighting started you know we
saw Ukraine as a way to wield power in
that region and we have been pushing
this so we got to be there we can't just
ditch our day to the dance the last
thing I would say is to take all of that
um President Biden didn't do an
end-of-year press conference I guess
this is going to have to suffice he
didn't get a question on our main issue
you brought it up judge and that is
right now the border and if he has if if
he believes that this fight is in our
national interest great we'll take we'll
take the argument we'll think it through
we'll make our decisions about that but
if you never address the border and you
don't explain why your decision making
is in our national interest it leaves
everyone to wonder why you are
abandoning the our troops our CBP on the
border and helping the ukrainians not
saying you shouldn't help the ukrainians
I want them to be helped but that is a
Communications failure that only comes
from the very top and you cannot leave
that to your underlings to do that in my
humble opinion sir hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else